cobra kai has captured the nostalgia of
a multi-generational franchise
but the characters aren't the only
things viewers find familiar
samantha's actress mary mouser has been
working for years
here's where you might have seen her
before prior to her role as sam larusso
on cobra kai actress mary mauser played
a recurring role on hulu's high school
horror series
freakish in that show a bunch of kids
show up for a detention but
find themselves fighting off killer
zombies after a nearby chemical plant
explodes
it's like the john hughes classic the
breakfast club except the kids in
detention
aren't just in trouble they're on the
menu mouser plays mary jones
little sister to grover another one of
the lead characters
those who survived the initial attack
must figure out how to make it out alive
without much in the way of supplies or
protection
mouser only had the role of mary for one
of the show's two seasons
which is a pretty good run considering
the body count of a zombie show
mary melser played the role of lacey
fleming on the medical crime meets
comedy drama series body of proof
prior to tying her ghee as sam larusso
before she was daniel sand's daughter
she was the nearly estranged daughter of
medical examiner megan hunt
a former neurosurgeon no longer able to
operate after suffering nerve damage in
a car crash
mouser's character was considered a
recurring role for the show's first
season at which time lacey lived with
her father mauser was promoted to the
main cast for the second
and third seasons as megan gains joint
custody with her ex-husband
and her relationship with her daughter
slowly evolves while lacey is shuttled
back and forth between parents
body of proof was cancelled by abc in
2013
after three seasons there are characters
on a tv show who shape the world of the
series with their presence
and then there are characters who rarely
appear but whose spirit hangs over
everything mauser got the opportunity to
play one such character
on cbs's long-running crime drama ncis
as the deceased daughter kelly of
special agent gibbs
mouser may have only appeared in a few
of the series's 400 plus
episodes but she's still arguably one of
the more important figures of the whole
show
at the beginning of ncis run fans were
left to guess as to why gibbs has such a
tough exterior and
often secretive personality that changed
in season 3
when the show revealed that he once had
a wife and daughter who were killed by a
member of a drug cartel
gibbs later killed the man in revenge
and the entire dark episode
and the memories of his past continued
to haunt him throughout his life
mauser played kelly in several flashback
sequences throughout the series
most notably in the episode's hiatus
parts 1 and 2.
while you might not recognize the
significantly younger mouser right away
ncis fans may have sensed kelly's
presence while watching cobra kai
typically when you see that somebody had
a one episode guest starring role on
criminal minds it's either because they
played a terrifying killer
or a terrified victim while the series
is known for its exceptionally grisly
cases
mouser's character from the season 10
episode emilia porter
survived with some deep emotional scars
but relatively minor physical ones
rebecca is a teenager who becomes one of
the targets of her uncle
benton farland who has recently been
released from prison after serving time
for the murder of rebecca's mother
while benton didn't kill rebecca's
mother himself he manipulated his
girlfriend at the time
the titular emilia porter to do so now
that he's a free man he desperately
wants to not only reunite with amelia
but
also have her recreate the murder he
coerced her into committing
unfortunately for rebecca she looks just
like her mother
so benton kidnaps her in preparation for
his twisted reunion
you don't recognize her it's rebecca
miriam's daughter
doesn't she look just like her mother
thankfully emilia isn't as interested in
playing along this time
she stalls long enough for the
behavioral analysis unit squad to show
up and rescue rebecca putting mouser in
this special category of criminal minds
guest stars whose characters didn't die
a horrific death
freeform's groundbreaking show the
fosters centers on steph
and lena adams foster a married couple
with a large family composed of their
biological
adopted and foster children
unsurprisingly the series featured a
sizable cast of characters throughout
its five-season run
including sarah lewis played by mouser
sarah only has a three episode arc on
the show
but they make up a pretty memorable
three episodes mauser plays a fellow
foster kid who meets cali
one of steph and lena's charges in a
therapy group
unfortunately for sarah she is being
groomed by one of cali's former foster
brothers
liam who callie knows to be manipulative
and regularly involved with girls who
are far
too young for him to be dating after
getting wrapped up in liam's criminal
activity
it looks like sarah may be at risk of
getting dragged down with liam but with
the help of cali
she's eventually able to break the spell
and turn against him
prank calls are all fun and games until
the playful charade starts to take on a
life of its own
and morph into something unsettling in
prank call
the season 3 episode of the hbo
anthology series room 104
mauser stars as a teenager who stumbles
into that lesson
in the worst possible way each episode
of room 104 focuses on a new temporary
inhabitant of the hotel room that gives
the series its name
in prank call that person is adrian
whose parents have left her alone for
the night
to pass the time adrian makes prank
calls far from lighthearted jokes
adrian's calls see her adopting personas
that are more grown up than she's ready
for
when she connects with a man named
george she lets her flirtatious older
woman persona get away from her
before she can put an end to the
disturbing situation
a knock on the hotel room door escalates
the prank to a terrifying degree
prank call is a twisted and often
disturbing episode of tv but it provides
mouser with a multi-layered part to sink
her teeth into
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you